I don't think men will ever understand
how deeply painful this is a film about
women made by and for women about the
difficulties of being a woman in the
modern patriarchal world and they didn't
even nominate the leading actress or the
female director yes how painful the Deep
searing pain of watching as a couple of
millionaire women you don't know aren't
nominated for Oscars well they were
nominated for Oscars in the screenplay
and producer categories but they weren't
nominated in the categories you want
which has caused you unimaginable
suffering and pain I mean you know there
are people in this world today at this
very moment who are malnourished who are
homeless who are starving who are uh
dying of horrible diseases who are
watching their family members die but
those people especially if they're men
cannot understand the depths of pain
that this girl on Twitter must be
feeling because Barbie was snubbed at
the Oscars